ça y est françois je suis prête il y a
dans ce panier tout ce qu'il faut pour à
technip en amour on y va mixu et bien
moi aussi je suis prêt il ne nous reste
plus qu'à attendre le facteur et
monsieur des snobs le
génie tu crois vraiment contre les
laisser sans crainte nous remplacer ont
écouté nous ont proposé gentiment nous
rendre service il faut être vu que
celui-ci au dernier moment nous manquons
de confiance en eux du réseau juristes
c'est idiot et lui se pique nique à
l'autre bout de l'île pour mais vraiment
d'être formidable tiens mais voici
mes très chers à l'échangé vous présente
toutes mes salutations c'est très gentil
à tous les âges taisez-vous pas de
remerciements et partait bien vite année
[Applaudissements]
ils sont pas sympathiques
amoché la mine vos réactions sont
empreintes d'un bon sens populaire dans
lequel on ne peut que s'incliner enfin
bon essayons de les remplacer de notre
mieux n'est-ce pas oui c'est vrai alors
que choisissez-vous les ballots ou les
bonbons les pense qu'il est de mon
devoir de prendre ce qu'il ya de plus
difficile c'est à dire le cut bon je ne
discute pas monsieur du stop bon alors
moi je choisis les ballons bien au
travail monsieur nous sommes au travail
[Applaudissements]
encore non jérémy ce dixième qu'on fait
exploser en cinq minutes pour sûr
monsieur du snob ce n'est pas aussi
facile que ça tout va bien vous y voir
a fait chauffer la colle à railler mon
cher emile moquez vous de moi c'est tout
mais pas ma faute si mademoiselle julie
france et beaucoup de bonbons sans tenir
compte des lois de l'équilibré oui c'est
ça fait tout de même le troisième que
vous faites tomber hasard malheureux mon
cher emi la maîtrise je suis un champion
du rangement rats il est vrai que vous
êtes un curieux personnage
[Musique]
j'ai chassé le lézard vert pendant trois
jours au congo j'ai jouer à saute d'un
point avec un chef des eskimos
je suis très ce taux chaque jour je
colle un gros oeuf d'autruche amant
petit déjeuner j'ai chanté un opéra dans
la rue à tombouctou trouver les trésors
cas dans un musée du périgord les gens
s'arrachent mais au togo on m'a reconnu
dans une renault quartier jeu
suis un champion de la sculpture
[Musique]
je
fait les chevreuse en peinture je suis
le plus grand le plus beau le plus fort
je connais le fils du frère de ma belle
soeur de marquis c'est un homme de
qualité la preuve ce qui me l'a dit
tess nord comme maicon un gros oeuf
d'autruche à son petit déjeuner
il sait parler sur ce noble avec un
accent anglais
moi j'y arrive beaucoup mieux avec la
sam à payer
j'ai lu talent c'est évident de toute ma
rue je suis la célébrité jeu
je suis un champion de la sculpture
[Musique]
heureux
je
fait les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture
je suis le plus grand le plus beau le
plus fort mais il m'arrive quelquefois
de faire un rêve un peu fou je m'appelle
monsieur durand et j'ai les mêmes que
jeanne supplice meurt alors je colle un
petit oeuf de poule qui me rend tout et
primaire
matin quand je m'éveille j'oublie mon
rêve et c'est bien je vois ma canne mon
chapeau et mon costume italien
je redeviens ce nom alors je colle un
gros oeuf d'autruche à mon petit
déjeuner
[Musique]
sera-t-on genre
mais tellement malheureux
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui ne va pas contents
ne supporte plus et pourquoi je suis là
je n'arriverai jamais à courir vite
c'est normal il n'y a pas de quoi
pleurer tu es une tortue et toutes les
tortues sont lentes c'est la nature tu
n'as aucune raison d'être malheureuse ne
supporte plus je voudrais tellement
pouvoir courir vite mais en quoi cela
tient-il d'être longue tous les lieux
qu'on se moque de moi
vous y voir les mets un peu compliqué
j'ai mal un culte
disons pourquoi
jusqu'à cannes a dit généralement une
tortue son se canto en moyenne mais ma
grand mère à 170 ans et elle se porte
encore très bien
maintenant dix mois juste à calvi un
lièvre cinq ans
si j'ai parfois s'il a la chance de ne
pas rencontrer de chasseurs
mais qu'est ce que toutes ces questions
ont à voir avec le fait que je souhaite
courir vite
général
écoute moi quand as tu ne supportes pas
les moqueries line et l'inflexion
stupide des liens qui se manque de
talent terre et bien crois moi il vaut
mieux que tu t'y habitues tout de suite
d'arthur que dix ans et tu vas dans
talons vie de rencontrer d'abord les
enfants des liens qui se sont manqués de
toit puis ensuite ce sera leurs
petits-enfants et leurs petits petits
enfants et ainsi de suite pendant toute
ta vie tu 8 donc 150 ans d'une vie de
tant qu divisé par cinq ans d'une vie de
lièvre égard
égale beaucoup beaucoup de lierre et
puis et puis regarde moi est-ce que je
m'occupe des moucherons qui se manque de
bol on est
allé samedi
[Musique]
cette bande à dd merveilleuse
quelque chose que nous allons vivre dans
une île où il fait toujours bon c'est
vrai que ça alors tu n'as pas trop de
dégâts aux bottes le facteur a fait
exploser une dizaine de mes ballons mais
enfin ça fait rien c'est pas trop
gravement dans julie proposons un petit
peu parce que vraiment nous avons
beaucoup marcher pour ce commencé à
avoir mal aux pieds
des corbeaux ah non non non non non
juline s'agit certainement pas d'un
corbeau menant le le corbeau c'est un
oiseau qu'on trouve dans les boues dans
les régions de plaine non ici dans l'île
aux enfants c'est certainement une une
mouette que tu as entendu mais non je
t'assure que c'était le cri d'un cambon
je connais très bien le cri des mois que
je les écoute tous les jours c'était le
cri d'accord vous admettons julia de
métaux alors dit moi as tu jamais vu
dans le ciel de ville aux enfants volés
un cordeau non évidemment
si t'arrives encore
une goutte de pluie
sur mon nez
un corbeau
tiens tu vois bien
enfin j'ai laissé c'est impossible
pourtant impossible ou pas moi j'aime
chercher à shanghai il commence à faire
froid
à propos quelle heure est il il est à
peine trois heures de l'après-midi
vraiment aujourd'hui dans le jardin de
l'île aux enfants il se passe vraiment
des choses étranges mais nous rêvons ou
quoi c'est impossible coûte le jour se
lève
on dirait qu'un orage a éclaté
tu crois moi je n'ai pas envie d'être
trempé son prétexte que c'est pas
possible après tout en abritant nous
puis tu rentres
merveilleux
absolument merveilleux
croyez vous abritez vous dire des choses
casimir casimir vient de casimir vient
quasiment
mais ce vent est glacial je lis tu
n'aurais pas une couverture
[Musique]
alors vite vite vite je lise gros lot
château rien du tout
bah oui le vent il est tombé
à vous tous et sortie n'est pas la seule
c'est raté casimir tu peux nous
expliquer ce que tout ceci signifie mais
enfin c'est pas la peine c'est raté ça
c'est trop fort explique toi bon voila
j'ai trouvé dans mon grenier un livre
ayant appartenu à mon ancien crack
casimir us merlin le magicien est dans
ce livre il y avait une recette pour
fabriquer une machine à faire la pluie
et le beau temps alors j'ai fabriqué la
machine malheureusement les deux
dernières pages du mode d'emploi étaient
arrachés alors ces rapts et une machine
faire la pluie et le beau temps dans une
île où il fait toujours beau hayes alors
toujours du soleil je mets un nuage
j'avais envie que ça change bien
heureusement que l'expérience a raté
casimir tu vas aller arrêter cette
machine immédiatement enfin ce n'est pas
la peine elles ne marchent pas
[Applaudissements]
quoi 4 4s casey mears est un oiseau qui
vit dans les pays où il fait très très
chaud casimir va arrêter cette machine
immédiatement bonbons jjp d'accord
mme rseq
tu as quelque chose à boire au caire
mais françois lebon se relève oui
il commence à neiger
site à près de toi casimir la machine
avec la vie
dralloc ou non non non moi je crois
plutôt qu'il s'agit des lions 15 mai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sera mieux tout d'un coup je sais c'est
bien là tout d'un coup c'est la machine
a explosé
mais alors comme un imbécile j'avais
laissé poser dessus
le livre de mon ancêtre casimir us
merlin si si bien que je ne pourrai plus
jamais faire la pluie et le beau temps
dans cette île vous me trouvez ionesco
pas du tout casimir elle ne regrette
rien c'est très bien comme ça
depuis longtemps que tu es capable de
nous faire rire comme de nous rendre de
mauvaise humeur oui et alors et alors
cela s'appelle faire la pluie et le beau
temps
[Applaudissements]